you can feel the moisture in the air if
you haven't stepped outside yet you
really need to maybe take your cup of
coffee and just get outside and enjoy
the moment humidity is up to around 75
percent dew points are in the 40s and
we've also got temperatures in some
neighborhoods a lot of neighborhoods in
the 40s much cooler than we were
yesterday morning and boy that moisture
is just really rich and we just don't
get many days like this we're so dry so
often here in the desert so 28 up there
kyle canyon yeah we had 40 50 mile an
hour winds in our area yesterday it was
just blowing and going but over in
northwest arizona around the grand
canyon check this out dust storms dust
storm warnings and advisories this was
around the grand canyon yesterday and
there were cars that just literally had
to stop
and wait it out because the dust was so
thick and it was so scary a lot of
people were putting posts on facebook
saying
i'm not as scared of the dust i'm scared
of the people who keep driving in this
reduced visibility and can't see where
they're going so this was a cbs morning
meteorologist from new orleans who was
on vacation and sent the video so thanks
so much for letting us share that
because these dust storms can be so
treacherous so the best thing to do is
just to pull over wait it out let the
the winds pass and the dust settle if
you can 48 in boulder city 53 in
mesquite 42 at indian springs this
morning and prump at 47. we did get some
nice rainfall last night and we were
looking for about an average of a tenth
of an inch and that's exactly what we
got for harry reid international a tenth
of an inch and that only gives us 16
hundredths of an inch for the year we
need to be at about an inch and three
quarters so we need another at least
half dozen good storms like we had last
night all right we picked up some nice
name rainfall around neighborhoods
around the valley over a tenth of an
inch at red rock the northeast valley
mountain's edge getting a 10th of an
inch boulder city got some nice rain all
coming up from the southwest to the
northeast even south of the valley too
it did pick up some nice rain
searchlight you picked up a little less
than two tenths of an inch kingman
three-quarters of an inch of rain and a
lot of these cells wound up with
lightning just as we were talking about
there was a a lot of convection in some
of these cells that produced that
lightning so the low itself still has to
spin its way out so that's why we're
still looking at maybe a little snow in
the mountains or some rain today with
mid 40s up there and in the valley late
today i'm talking four five six o'clock
we might still see a stray shower high
today will be cooler in the low 70s then
this system's gone and we're drying out
warming up to finish march near 80
degrees 81 for april fool's day on
friday mid 80s for the weekend and a
slight chance of showers again on monday
we'll take it we need it